welcome back if you find yourself
struggling with hair loss but don't know
why Kelly nimiro of Wellness by Kelly
the sponsors of today's segment is here
to break it all down for us Kelly always
so great to see you thank you so much
for having me this is a really important
thing to talk about so let's just jump
right into it what are some of the
causes of hair loss it's so interesting
so there can be a variety of different
things that we don't really think about
like your iron levels your diet what
your thyroid is doing there's hormonal
causes it can really vary from person to
person so getting your Labs checked is
really priority number one but what I
don't think a lot of people know is that
up to 50 percent of women at the age of
50 will experience hair loss up to 30
percent of women at the age of 30 will
experience hair loss and like not little
like shedding because we all experience
hair is falling out every single day but
severe hair loss where you're noticing
it at the temples and on the scalp wow
that really puts it into perspective
that we all could experience this and go
through something like this and what are
some things that we can all do to help
alleviate the loss of our hair are there
even just kind of everyday things that
we can put into our schedule and
routines yes absolutely so like I said I
think the first thing is getting to the
root cause of why you're losing your
hair so if you look at the picture on
the screen that was me my thyroid was so
out of whack and so my hair was falling
out in clumps and I had no idea why the
second I got that sorted out my hair
started growing back if your ferritin
level is below 40 your hair is going to
keep falling out until you get that
corrected so root causes first next is
eating a lot of protein and healthy fat
that's what our hair is created out of
those hair cells are created from
healthy fat and protein getting enough
hydration not putting too much damage
too much heat on your hair not coloring
it too often brushing it from the tip to
the root rather than the root to the tip
so there are definitely things that you
can be doing but getting to the root
causes most important wow even simple
things like that I've never even heard
of that before so I will definitely keep
that in line and you touched on it in
the beginning and I follow along with
you on social media you're very adamant
about getting your Labs checked in
sometimes the average person just
doesn't even know what to look for so
that's something that you kind of coach
and can help people get through that
process right absolutely and so we'll
when I first meet with clients if
they're telling me hair loss is one of
the things that they're looking for I
check off all the boxes okay are we
going to test your iron levels yes are
we going to check your thyroid levels
yes are we going to check your insulin
and blood sugar because even things like
that we don't necessarily think of but
they can cause hair loss well Kelly
thank you so much for always giving us
such helpful information and if you're
not already following her on social
media you have to because you give some
really great tips I love following along
and thank you to Wellness by Kelly for
sponsoring this segment for more
information you can scan that QR code
right there on your screen or visit
wellnessby kelly.com and uh she's giving
us a special offer seven day free trial
and membership is only 19.99 per month
Las Vegas now we'll be right back
[Music]